foreign
[Music]
everyone the monsters from a quiet place
are coming back the two movies from
Paramount have already been very
successful with horror fans but those
responsible including actor and director
John Krasinski are working on further
installments while the story of the
Abbott family is to be continued in a
quiet place 3. today's original is about
the prequel with the title day one we
will tell you everything it is known so
far about the story the cast and the
production
the previous a quiet place movies mainly
revolve around the fate of the Abbott
family they live in a world that has
been invaded by mysterious alien
creatures the monsters are blind but can
detect even the slightest of sounds in
the course of the story The Family keeps
developing new strategies to handle the
danger for example they use a cochlear
implant to disorient the monsters and
later even multiply the signal using a
radio tower in 2025 their story will be
continued in part three but prior to
that the prequel day one will be
released the name already indicates
which time period will be in Focus here
namely the moment of the invasion this
marks a distinct change from the
previous post-apocalyptic setting rather
it's about the downfall of humanity as
we know it entirely new characters are
also to be introduced just last month
Emily Blunt the lead actress of a quiet
place and a quiet place too spoke about
the prequel in an interview with
deadline she revealed what a potential
appearance of her own character may be
all about she first clarified that this
was actress Lupita nyong'o's movie and
not hers but the connections would
become apparent once you saw the
finished film that's all she could
reveal at the moment her ambiguous
answer can be read as meaning that the
Abbott family plays a role in day one
albeit not as the center of the plot
there are clear signs of the return of
another character we are talking about
the nameless leader of an island
community at the end of a quiet place
too in the sequel he tells how he and
his people were taken to an Island by
the National Guard after the invasion
became known since the creatures can't
swim we might learn more about the group
in their lives before the invasion in
the prequel but it's hard to say how big
their part will be in the end overall
the movie will probably be much more
International for example the start of
shooting took place in London while the
main storyline is set in New York City
especially at the beginning of the movie
it would make sense to show the alien
invasion in several places around the
world it would be exciting to see how
the many countries of the world react to
the new danger before they ultimately
collapse some are hoping for more
insight into the death angels as the
monsters in the franchise are called
from the prequel they mainly prey on
humans and it's not entirely sure why
they actually landed on Earth and what
planet they came from in the first place
their mysterious background raises many
questions we are eager to find out
whether the new movie will answer some
of them
several actors have already been
confirmed for the cast of a quiet place
day one the presumed lead role will be
played by 12 Years a Slave in Black
Panther star Lupita Nyong'o she also has
experience in the horror genre having
featured in Jordan peele's ass and the
horror comedy little monsters for
example the cast also includes jimon
hansu who will once again play the
Island's leader Alex Wolff who has been
cast is no stranger to the horror genre
either he played the 16 year old son in
the acclaimed hereditary and is also
part of the cast in the upcoming
historical drama Oppenheimer by
Christopher Nolan last but not least the
current cast is completed by stranger
things Star Joseph Quinn who played fan
favorite Eddie in the Netflix series
back in November 2020 Paramount Pictures
announced that they were working on a a
quiet place spin-off it was originally
to be written and directed by Indie
director Jeff Nichols a year later
however it was announced that Nichols
and Paramount were parting ways due to
creative differences then in January
2022 director Michael sarnoski was
signed on as a replacement best known
for his Nicholas Cage film Pig he took
over the screenplay as well filming has
been completed for several months
already and took place from February to
April 2023. the theatrical release of a
quiet place day one is scheduled for
March 8 2024.
we hope you enjoyed our new Original
Episode what are your high hopes for the
prequel and do you think Emily blonde or
John Krasinski will be making a small
appearance feel free to tell us in the
comments and let us know if you want to
learn more about a quiet place 3.
[Music]